nous sommes aujourd'hui dans ce lieu
emblématique du conseil général le
jardin de l'État pour la manifestation
donc la juné grand public de
manifestation santz-vous sport ces
gens-là n'ont pas attendu une journée
pour faire du sport bien évidemment donc
la gymnastique volontaire est organisée
à réunion donc nous sommes présents dans
22 communes donc du département donc
avec une cinquantaine d'associations qui
fonctionnent déjà mais le but de cette
journée c'est surtout de s'adresser aux
personnes qui ne nous connaissent pas
qui connaissent pas la gyastique
volontaire et qui ne pratiquent pas de
sport donc on est sur un temps
d'information mais aussi c'est un temps
de témoignage par rapport au bienfait de
l'activité physique donc on fait
découvir donc des activités on dit aux
gens il faut pratiquer l'activité
physique pour être en pleine forme et
pour garder la forme et surtout pour
bien vieillir pour ceux qui sont moins
le on va chercher le
cieleppous
hein on est sur une activité physique
adaptée donc à tout type de public qu'on
soit comme je vous disais qu'on soit
jeune moins jeune malade porteur de
handicap maladie chronique diabè et
cetera donc c'est ce que vous pourrez
trouver aujourd'hui une activité adressé
à tout le monde le sport santé est
aujourd'hui repris par l'ensemble des
ligues sportives même au niveau du
football même au niveau du handball donc
il y a je crois qu'il y a une
sensibilisation au plus haut niveau de
l'État euh par rapport à cet aspect euh
du sport santé de la pratique sportive
on voit bien ben les comptes de la
Sécurité sociale comment ils sont et
donc la pratique sportive faire en sorte
que le maximum de monde pratique une
activité physique a un bienfait non
seulement donc sur la santé mais c'est
aussi au-delà de la santé au-delà au
niveau des dépenses publiques bien
bouger bien bouger à demain bien bouger
bien bouger ça bon pour la santé bien
bouger bien bouger chacun il fait comme
il peut bien bouger bien bouger
ouais content de cette dynamique il faut
que ça passe il faut que ça bouge et ce
beau témoignage par la présence de ce de
à peu près 500 ou 600 personnes qui sont
déjà inscrit ce matin ben c'est déjà une
belle réussite pour ce début de matinée
donc il faut que la Réunion
bouge